joining us right now uh here on this
show
um is a man who i think he announced his
retirement literally a half an
hour before he went on the air and he's
uh retiring from uh
the national football league and now
heading into the world of podcasting
after a dozen years of playing
uh with distinction uh a man um who was
drafted in the 2008 first round
um by the tampa bay buccaneers and the
super bowl champion
with the denver broncos in super bowl 50
akib to leave here on the rich eisen
show how are you keeb
i'm good fellas what's going on we are
pleased that you have
decided to uh call into our show the day
that you retired why did you uh decide
to
no longer play the national football
league
uh it's i think i lost it
in in my heart you know what i'm saying
that's kind of how i explained it on my
show i couldn't really dive into it
on my podcast but you know you got that
feeling rich
if you got it you got it when you lose
that feeling you kind of know you lose
that feeling you know what i'm saying so
that little itch for the game that
competitive edge
i think i think that kind of that kind
of left me man you know
i don't know what the reason for that
being you know maybe it's your age
maybe you're seeing your kids grow up
you want to be home more it's a lot of
things that play parts in that but
all in all i just thought it was the
right time for me is it
a fact akib that you told bill belichick
um
no when he offered you a job to play in
2020 is that a fact
oh it's definitely definitely a fact uh
i appreciate bill too man he uh he
always got me in mind every time i'm
free
every time it's a anything anytime this
ikea
lead may change teams bill is always
checking on me and he always i'm always
on his mind man i think
i think he respects me as a player
respect what i do on the field and man i
definitely
respect him as a coach man how can he
not and i and i really respect him as a
gm man because
bill gonna call you he gonna tell you
live and direct what do you think and
you know i'm saying
what we can do so i just always loved
working with him
and uh y'all feel bad
honestly rich i felt bad man i i really
wanted to do it but like i said it just
it just wasn't there you know what i'm
saying
well what was his offer akib
rich i don't want to put all the numbers
out there but it was decent it was a
nice vetted contract
i maybe could have brought home five and
a half six million dollars it was
it was it was a it would have been not
too hard for me to bring that home
either so
that's right it's a decent contract
right and um
and what would your role have been for
new england
it would i would i would have had a uh
tight end guardian and if anything you
tune in tune into the show with the call
to the booth
and i really i really tell the long the
long haul long version of the story
but it would have been a nice you know
inside road
dime version of a safety kind of road
a lot a lot of tight ends guarding a lot
of tight ends
okay well i you know that's a veteran
move broadcasting
already akib for a veteran of the nfl
going into broadcasting
which is to promote your show and
mention your show a couple of times and
also say to tune in
tune in for the real estate no i
understand no it makes it makes complete
sense and we'll get to your podcast
uh in a second let's talk about uh your
career
your greatest achievement on the
football field would be what
super bowl 50 definitely uh that
probably was the best feeling that i
ever had
playing football ever in my life so
second to none hands down it was it was
the confetti falling super bowl 50
looking for my family at the end of that
game that had to be the number one
feeling
of my entire career and then playing in
the super bowl
against new england uh with the rams
akeeb
what was it like that day going against
tom brady in a
brutal defensive battle that was a
points challenge to fair
man it was uh it was it was a movie
[ __ ]
it was pre-game the whole you know the
whole
experience atlanta experience man it was
my second one so
so you know i kind of was a little
calmer this time i kind of really got to
sit back and
you know take it all in but uh just
preparing against those guys man
watching time watching
the different ways they can attack you
man uh
seeing shine and that offensive jared
and that offense just you know
get ready for the many ways that they
can attack you on defense and uh
it was just a great football experience
man something i could say
i did in my career you know just
prepared against tom brady
in the super bowl against bill belichick
in the super bowl man
julian edelman grant the whole cast so
man it was this
it's just the the process of doing it is
so
you know i'm saying it's satisfying just
even before the game the whole process
leading up to the game sitting in that
room and watching this tape
is just so satisfying man so i i
definitely enjoyed it well you know what
saints fans would say about you and the
rams being in that game what was your
perspective
uh of the niquel roby-coleman non-call
were you
near it were you where were you at that
very moment in time i really was kind of
close
uh i was on uh mike thomas i think he
ran like a little five-yard sit-down
route and we was kind of in the slot so
uh i really i really seen it i really
was pretty close to it
and it's fast man rich you know football
is fast stuff happens fast
and it happened so fast i didn't i
didn't really know what happened to ref
he ain't know what happened as well so
he just let us play so
you got to understand that we not we not
fans
at that moment we actually playing in
the game and they actually
refine the game and stuff is actually
happening live so
you're not going to just catch
everything to me honestly it looked like
a bang bang play
i thought i'm like bro you should have
picked it that's what i that's
my first thing i'm like bro bro you
should have picked it i thought he
should have intercepted the ball
and i didn't my first thought when oh
his passing appearance i thought like oh
you missed the pick
that's the first thing that came to my
head so football happens fast man so hey
they blew it they blew it
it's not the first it won't be the last
no i know but you're retired now
um is that past interference thecube now
that you've seen its second third fourth
uh thought hell yeah it was past the
event
it definitely was passive affairs he was
early as well yes
okay that's what i [ __ ] had though
stuff happens fast well yeah and so does
obviously the end of uh
the end of stays at teams as you know um
jalen ramsey was acquired by the rams
and then you
were were sent to miami where you know
you never played and now
obviously you're retired and on the day
where jalen ramsey hits it and hits it
very large with a five-year 105 million
dollar contract does it at least give
you
some sort of solace in the fact that the
rams paid him uh
in in swapping out in a way or they let
they led you to the past i don't really
look at it like that really look at it
it's the business that i'm in you know
what i'm saying they had a chance to get
jalen
you got to get jalen how can you not so
i don't look at it like well at least
they paid them
they got rid of me for now i am i'm
happy for a matter of fact i just talked
to him this morning
reggie and that training staff face
tommy you know i'm saying just you know
congratulate me on my career and stuff
and uh
put jalen on he was in the training room
you know hanging out
and uh i told him congrats this morning
so that's a friend of mine so i don't
even really look at it like that
it's business at the end of the day it's
a business
so and i've been in it for a decade plus
so i fully understand the business out
of it
the keep to leave here on the rich eisen
show the daily retirees let's talk about
your podcast again
a multi-platform podcast uh called call
to the booth podcast with you and
michael crabtree did i get that right
hey hey he should have did the show with
me man we would have win
crazy called me man you know i'm saying
yeah we have fire hands and we have made
crowds you're the co-host
hey we'll go nuts man let's put our
differences aside we really already did
for real
okay so hit me up crap let's let's you
could be the co-host of the show babe
you know what i mean look it's with
harrison sanford which is an interesting
way for me to describe
uh um michael crabtree so i mean
are you are you guys like what was that
all about
what's that man man crabtree yeah it's
just football you know
it's football we don't live in the same
city things got kind of heated you know
it's entertainment at the same time
it's you know it's part of what we do
it's part of our business
we we talked since then i ran into him
all right and here in the city we talked
since then
man i think we good okay that's good
well i i think he'd be a great guest for
your podcast i certainly would tune in
yeah yeah i gotta i gotta hit him up
okay we're really good
okay so let's uh let's uh let's you know
obviously kick the the tires here on
your
being part of the paparazzi who do you
have winning super bowl 55.
55 uh it's hard not to teach rick
it's hard it's hard not to pick the
chiefs again just because i
i don't see no matter what they do on
defense they got they got great they got
a great leader on defense so
and they got a great defensive
coordinator so i think the scheme
and time matthew himself he gonna make
the delete the defense believe
that they're the best in the league
that's that's the kind of guy that's the
kind of guy he is
and that was the kind of guy i was rich
when i was in the locker room with god
you know
it's blue guys who like that they just
make everybody around them think they
good but you think they're good you know
i'm saying you have everybody believing
we good so i think the defense gonna
handle itself
right and patrick mahone's in that
offense man
can't nobody stop that so can't nobody
stop it uh
i don't see him it's gonna be hard for
the chiefs not to win again
bar injury i'm picking the cheats rich
okay it's a barring injury
um and i guess last question for you
here on live television and streaming
um is brady and belichick on separate
teams
um how do you think either one is
approaching the season obviously they're
focused on the task at hand
but exactly how do you i know that
they're going to focus on the task at
hand we in the media
are not though you're now part of you
you you are now part of this how do you
think either man
when they're maybe alone thinks about
this
uh i don't know it's it's to me it's
like
it's a relationship almost you know i'm
saying i work it's a work relationship
you know what i'm saying we work
together we we really the head of the
ship
both of us really and
if we split you know it's going to be
you're going to think about him you know
he gonna cross your mind time gonna
cross his mind bill's gonna cross his
mind
and uh at the same time it's a business
they gotta get to it you don't really
have no time to wait you don't have no
time to believe
coach right here and moyes always say
that well you don't got no time to
really dwell on it right you got to move
on
but i think i think they definitely both
both had a place in their heart for each
other man
you know that work relationship you've
been so successful it's hard not to you
know
have a relationship with somebody
there's no doubt about it i mean 20
years is remarkable we'll never see that
again
and and i know and we always talk about
how brady left and
what i mean it's 20 years i mean it it
it was that long and so it's kind of
understandable that maybe before it is
all over for a quarterback
wanting to try someone else i get it but
when you were there in new england did
you see any
gear grinding that led you to believe
that this could possibly happen one day
nah it was it was it was uh uh
normal when i was there at least from
the you know outside looking in i don't
really know the
ins and outs of it but bill did what he
did man he treated everybody the same
here get on time just like he'd get on
me get on grunt
you know whoever you know a rookie a guy
who i don't even know his name
so they'll treat everybody the same in
the building so
it was normal to me it looked look
regular from my point of view
okay hey akeeb thanks for joining on the
day that you have retired congrats on uh
stepping into the podcasting world with
call to the booth
uh episodes drop wednesdays and
thursdays throughout the 2020 season
where
podcasts can be gotten come back here on
the show if you want me to return the
favor
and be a home at home and be on the pod
i'm i'm more than happy to do it
hey i appreciate that rich i i'm gonna
hold you to that
when you get a text from me and i'm
saying telling you a time in the place
okay you got no we got it we gotta run
it rich you got it thanks for the call
akib you take care
thank you you got it that's thecube to
leave hey you watched all the way to the
end thanks for that
watch more right here